what's that belief nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet I
started to believe life series to help
us learn a little bit more about
ourselves grow personally and ideally
bring some of what we learned about
ourselves to our business to have more
success so today we're gonna learn how
to motivate yourself rule number four is
my personal favorite and I'd love to
know which one you guys like the best
also as you're watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
I put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired by it as well and if you
leave it within the first couple hours
of this video going live you have a
chance to win one of two daily prizes
[Music]
we're all given a certain amount of time
to experience life to carry out our
dreams our destiny but we don't realize
that the time-bar of our life can only
grow smaller from today going forward
let that sink in you can't buy time you
can't grow time you can't ask for more
time you can only lose time and after we
lose time we have no idea how much time
we even have left our lifespan is a
mystery see being human is a
double-edged sword because although we
have so much time compared to other
species we give ourselves too much time
to accomplish what needs to be done the
idea of having so much more time to
accomplish things makes us waste time we
abuse it it feeds our lack of action it
makes us too comfortable now we all aim
to succeed to prosper to become a
diamond in a world full of rocks but
there's no evolutionary pressure to help
us and that's where the mind shift needs
to take place you need to create a
pressure for yourself to become that
diamond and the way that you do that is
by understanding the
all you of time stop killing time
because eventually that turns around and
tie was gonna kill you you have the
power to prevent time loss you have the
power to prevent wasted time but you
also have the power to kill time and
many of us are doomed
before we make decisions before we act
we need to think about how we're
spending our time we need to focus on
what we want to accomplish what makes
the heart burn with passion what wakes
us up in the morning what's your why
time is the most valuable resource we
have I could save money for later I
can't do that with my time I get
invested in our money I can't do that
with time I can share my money I still
can't do that with time stop damaging
your lifespan sooner or later you're
going to realize that the only thing you
wish to have more off is time but it's
what you use the worst
let me tell you something to em your
motives listen to me when you get to a
point where you start living certain
things you ain't gonna say it you ain't
gotta be a walking billboard right
people will know who you are not about
what you say or claim you are but
they'll know who you are by your spirit
are you hearing upset and that's my last
one motive what's your motive there are
a lot of people you're not successful in
life not because you ain't got talent
not because you ain't got skills but
your character ain't right and I've told
you this before then if you're not
careful your talent would take you
places that your character can't keep
you are you hear what I'm saying your
talent would take you places your
character can't keep you so what's your
motive there are people out there who
called me et I want to be a speaker why
you're trying to blow up you're trying
to be seen or are you trying to help
people are you trying to minister to
people are you trying to help people
they like or you're trying to blow up
all right so somebody came in my life
the other day and told me they wouldn't
be famous I said what you want to be
famous and they're like I don't know
what I want to be famous in I just want
to be able to walk through the mall and
they shut it down listen to me what's
your motive why do you do what you do
and that's so important it's not enough
just to be a doctor you got doctors who
got terrible bedside manners terrible
you got lawyers who are skilled but
arrogant and we talked about character
right now what's your motive why do you
do what you do are you doing what you're
doing to help people to benefit me we
say 80 you ain't trying to get paid this
to me very closely look when you good at
what you do and you're looking out for
people are you hear what I'm saying
listen to me I've cracked codes I've
been able to get into places other
people don't get into why because people
understand they understand they're 80 we
know why he do what he do it he is
trying to help us not hurt us are you
hearing me and so I'm gonna let you
listen to this I'm gonna let you listen
to the why we took it down from the site
let's say I'm gonna put it back up just
the audio I want you to listen to it but
but before you before we go remember the
I and I did that's good
a action that's important but the
motivation is important why because when
you look at the word you got two things
you got motive and then action right so
motive is important because what's
driving your action now hear what I'm
saying even in your action while your
action is
good you've got to ask what drives it
what guides it what moves it what's the
spirit behind it what's the reason
behind it what's the purpose behind it
are you hear what I'm saying
that's just as critical as the action
itself so the reason why you can't get
up at 4:00 o'clock in the morning the
reason why when I say get up at 6:00 you
looking at me like I'm crazy it's
because you don't have that thing that's
driving you that's pushing you to say no
to your arm clock and wake up no to the
snooze but when you get that extra
assignment that extra lot the reason why
you can't do it is because you don't
have the right hmm you ain't got the
right you ain't got the right hmm that
motive that's pushing the action and so
I want you to listen to the Y and at the
end of it I want you to write down what
motivates you and when you write it down
if it's just money listen to me boo if
it's just money you gonna make it and
then what's gonna happen right if it's
just to be see if it's just about you
when you get in the gated community when
you get that European vehicle when you
blow up what side what do you do after
that are you hearing me if you make it
to the NFL
and that's only a three year span ten
years at most if you make it to the NBA
and you retire you still 32 33 what's
after that so what you made it to the
league so what you want you want a
championship so what you to MVP so what
you you want to score in title what's
after that so what you you got the
Lombardi Trophy so what you got the
rushing title so what you got the most
runs the most yards in the NFL what's
after that so what's your motivation
what moves you what drives you and you
will hear me saying Moses the King died
I don't know how much money he made but
I know it's motivation he moved the
world I don't know how much money mother
Teresa may but I know she changed the
world I don't know how much money Gandhi
made but I know he changed the world
what's your why a lot of people think
they'll have motivation one day then
they'll put the effort up it's like
motivation first they think then effort
comes the motivation inspires the effort
right it's actually the opposite in the
science of motivation it's with daily
effort that motivation comes I like to
tell people this with momentum
more motivation don't wait for the
motivate motivation to go out and take
action actually take action first
because just a little bit of progress a
few quick wins drops dopamine into the
brain we start feeling good and rewarded
for our behavior and suddenly you find
ourselves more motivation so here's a
thing set three goals each day knock off
each of those three goals if you just
did that each and every single day you'd
start feeling more personal power and
you start getting ahead I started
shaving my hair not sixteen years old
and the feeling I had every morning I
looked in the mirror was horrible and I
don't want to feel like that anymore and
how I felt was a kid going nowhere a kid
that was scared and most kids will
accept that and look for help
but the best thing that happened to me
no one helped me no one felt sorry for
me
no one looked at me and said like this
day and age they'll they'll take you in
and they'll tell you bye stop picking on
this person back then they didn't care
the KKK marched in our 4th of July
parades they had to stay 100 yards back
but they marched in it Wow that's how
this town was and my mom cared about me
but my dad took our soul and she did you
know did the best she could I had to
figure out I wasn't going to be a punk
kid all my life so in a way I could turn
around was to suffer I had to build
calluses in my brain the same way I
built calluses on my hands so I brought
the Guinness Book of World Records for
puffs a long time ago but I felt at it
twice and I did 67,000 pull-ups and
trying to break this record
so to do 4030 pull-ups I had to do
67,000 for training for that Wow
and so what I realized is for me to
become the man I wanted to become I saw
myself as the weakest person God ever
created but I never blamed God for
anything he did to me so I wanted to
change that to be the hardest man ever
created in my that I don't know but you
had to have a goal and my goal when I
was sitting there not going to school
being bullied being having no
self-esteem
my goal was the only person that's gonna
turn this person around it's me you know
where I can turn around
has put myself through the worst things
possible a human being can ever endure
it and that be the only way that I can
build this brain to handle anything that
comes in front of it
callus in my mind through pain and
suffering in the end like what would
your advice be to that 16 year old kid
who's staring in the mirror does not
like what he sees but is still running
from adversity well my biggest advice to
him is that first of all he won't like
what I say to him and I'm gonna say the
exact opposite of what the world today's
world is saying so we read a bunch of
books nowadays as humans we we want to
find out how to be someone else what we
don't do is we don't go inside so
literally turn yourself inside out read
the book that says like we're writing a
book every day of our lives but we never
read that book so what I would challenge
this young man or young woman to do is
you have to look inside of yourself to
see what you really want what are you
passionate about we use these words and
these little phrases of only the strong
survive and also the crap they're all
just in words I get so tired of hearing
people just talking that right now
someone may think Dogma is just talking
you don't know me so when I speak I
speak from Pasha I speak from experience
I speak from suffering I want to tell
this young man and woman that the only
way I believe and this is just my
experience in life the only way you're
ever going to get to the other side of
this journey is you have got to suffer
to grow to grow you must suffer and some
people will get it and some people won't
but they have to see what their journey
is to start their journey several people
live to be a hundred years old and they
have great lives and they have great
kids the kids go to college and all sort
of stuff but somewhere in their life
there was a point where they had a
decision to make they can go left or
right on this path left was the easy
route right was a hard route a lot of
people take the easy route and they had
a good life that way but the better life
was going to the right side and you may
have twenty years of pain and suffering
to get past it but a lot of us died
never truly starting our journey and I
will tell this John
person you got to start your journey it
may suck but it will it will come out
the other side we are coasting if you
find your passion you're gonna have this
tremendous energy of sustainable energy
but momentum requires you always do the
next thing that keep the momentum going
and the reason you get yourself in a
passionate place is so that you change
your life and the only thing that
changes your life is making a decision
so while you're in this passionate state
that's where you make decisions you
don't make decisions when you're like
huh I don't know what do you think
all right let's decide if you make a
decision in a state without momentum if
you make a decision from a place where
there's no passion you are not gonna get
momentum it'll kill momentum
it's decide commit and resolve some of
you in the past you've gotten momentum
you've gotten passionate you've even
made a decision but a decision is the
first step
decision is like a war I gotta do this
or that all right I'm gonna make myself
through this but commitment is when you
nail after you've decided you commit to
do this for the long term whether it's
hard or easy doesn't matter you're doing
this it takes it from this moment and it
carries it in the future
even when things are difficult and the
third state is resolved resolved
means it's done it's like it doesn't
even if you took actually it's done
inside you so it's done out there
there's no question whatsoever then once
you decide the only way that commitment
and the energy and the momentum
continues is if you take immediate
massive what my friends massive life
write down in your notes massive action
is the cure-all massive action is the
cure-all if you're having a difficult
time with something your relationship
isn't where you want it to be your
finances are not
your body's not where you want to be
your business is not where you want to
be you need take massive action and if
that doesn't work try something else so
that's his work try something else keep
going with massive action and you will
find the way because it will give you
momentum how do we get people to become
success seekers rather than failure
avoiders first day of introductory
psychology class I teach two classes of
600 students maybe some of you have been
in that class and remember the first day
I say how many are here to avoid failure
at 80% raise your hand and I say well
thanks for coming I know you're
motivated but you're not happy campers
you probably told your friends I got to
go to class it's a requirement not I get
to go to class it's an opportunity you
probably woke up to an alarm clock not
an opportunity clock and it's all in how
you see it really it's all in how you
see it
it's your paradigm it's how you
communicate to others and how you
communicate to yourself so Ellen Langer
said in her book mindfulness she said
and psychologists know when you perceive
choice you perceive motivation you're
more motivated so the deal is for
yourself sit back and reflect being
mindful of the choices you have and talk
about being a success Seager rather than
a failure of order it's all how you talk
how you communicate to yourself and to
others
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what did you think what did
you learn from this video that you're
going to apply immediately somehow to
your life or to your business leave it
down in the comments below I'm really
excited to hear from you and if you'd
leave a comment within the first few
hours of this video going live you might
win one of our two daily prizes I also
want to give a quick shout-out to jamya
expose thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word the
eBook version and reading it and sharing
it to your audience
I really really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the
book thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
thing you should fear in your life is
that you waste your life
this precious thing that you've got this
one chance
this one instance this one shot that you
get
just one do you realize what this life
is I feel like people don't really
understand what what life is I mean what
is life look at look at your hands like
look around you it's amazing it's pure
magic the average guy he lacks the
skills to do anything productive in his
life if he decides to take on a new diet
he'll drop it you probably won't even
finish reading the diet book if he
decides to go to the gym and he's tired
after he gets home from work he says I'm
tired I am NOT going to the gym today
because I'm tired my emotions tell me
not to go to the gym so I'm not going to
gym because my emotions said so a lot of
people simply do not have standards
they're willing to let their life slide
the ones are life to let the life just
ooze on by and they lack a sense of
urgency about the direction of their
life is going
is what you want
to live a nice happy life with a simple
family and a nine-to-five job in a
retirement that is what you're going to
do with your one life what are some
examples of things that are pathetic not
having your held Handelman pathetic not
living in a situation that you're
comfortable in because you were lazy
pathetic and how about not having the
type of dating life that you want or sex
life that you want if you don't have
that it is pathetic
that's it that's what you're gonna do
you're gonna go I'm gonna punch the
clock
for eight nine hours a day for 40 years
of your life you will work you have no
emotional connection to doing work that
is it serving the universe or the world
and any especially important way and
they're gonna do that over and over and
over again so the reason why people
don't put action behind their work and
their thought process and then and what
they're saying is because they lose the
motivation they lose that fire inside
and beyond that just what is what is
this reality that we inhabit it's like
pure magic
it really is and yet what do you do with
it you you take this magical thing and
what have you done with it you made
yourself bored and miserable and
depressed and whining and complaining
and fishing and moaning and acting the
victim and being unmotivated and being
petty worrying about stupid things
holding negative judgments and opinions
of others taking all of this for granted
[Music]
imagine right now that I told you that
you only have till the end of today to
live where every milestone while you
might be excited about the milestone
there's a part of the milestone that you
don't want to face are you hearing me
and listen to me I knocked out the
courseware boom got it done in order ET
why did it take you two years
eg after you finish your coursework why
did it take you two years to get started
with the dissertation I'm gonna be 100
with you then with one look knocked all
the course work out but when I finally
got to the dissertation I had to get to
that demon I had to deal with it I had
to face it face one we're not talking
about elementary school middle school
high school I've had a professor or two
tell me in college that you will never
get your dissertation that that that
while you're writing has improved but in
terms of your analysis like you are not
critical enough to do a dissertation are
you here with
telling you we're talking about look
math I love math coming up why it is
what it is so please excuse my dear Aunt
Sally like it is what it is right it's
not subjective writing is subjective
I've had teachers to look at my work at
it and and ship it in the park and the
fear to fear what the fear of rejection
right this is if my teachers were so
subjective I put my whole heart into it
I put everything I can put and they tell
me edit it again a revision after
revision and it after are you hear what
I'm telling you I had to deal with the
fact that writing has never really been
my strong suit and even though I've
worked hard and I put in hours and hours
in the back of my mind I in the back of
my mind I could hear the teacher say
Ichi you'll have what it takes to get a
dissertation I'm a grown man dealing
with that fear I'm a grown man I'm
dealing with the rejection of getting
all that read all that read on my paper
of having and do it over and over and
over and over and come on come on
somebody fills me you feel like you'll
do a hundred and twenty percent you'll
give everything you have and it still
won't be enough I feel you I was there a
part of the milestone is what does I
give everything and it ain't enough what
if I put my whole heart my whole mind my
whole soul into it
et and it's not enough what am i doing
in our fam and so I feel you so you're
just like you're not gonna do it all
because you rather not do it and find
out the truth and I'm telling you got to
be a pavement we gotta face your fear
and you guys do it anyway your sweat et
had to face his fear that's right yup I
know you see Ichi be slow and you right
I am be smoked but it don't mean be
smart without fear it don't mean be
smart without lure anxiety and don't
mean be smart and I'm just 120% sure no
I have to live my faith - and I made up
in my mind et you got to go after eat
look I finished my coursework it took me
two years why cuz it took me two years
to get over the fear it took me two
years to get over the anxiety it took me
two years to finally say Goliath here I
come Goliath you might be taller than me
you might be bigger than me you might be
stronger than me but I'm coming and
rather die trying I'd rather die going
after this dissertation I'd rather give
everything our guy rather give a year
I'd rather put it in work and fail you
cannot try it off you have to focus now
before you turn off the video are going
next one listen to this a lot of people
have that initial desire but they don't
look at their goals every single day
they don't revisit every single let's
say Sunday and say how did I do this
week how do I do in my health in my
relationships in my career how did I do
with my finances how did I do with any
other goals that I set up you have to
have that daily discipline to look and
focus on what you're doing and that
weekly review you also have to have the
ability to avoid distractions one of the
reasons people love my book the
motivation manifesto is this teaches you
how to set boundaries how to say no how
to push away distraction to own your
life again